l'adieu du peuple d'angleterre à sa
princesse la commune était là recueilli
silencieuse pour rendre un dernier
hommage à lady diana d'abord sur le
parcours jusqu'à l'abbaye de wesminster
puis tout au long du trajet qui devait
l'amener à sa dernière demeure une
petite ligne sur un lac à près de son
village dalton
madame monsieur bonsoir nous allons
revenir dans un instant sur ses obsèques
simple et émouvante puis nous parlerons
des autres titres de l'actualité
l'émotion en un an après la mort de mère
teresa le nouveau massacre en algérie
dans un faubourg de la capitale le
voyage de jacques chirac en mauritanie
et la mort d'un grand chef georg chulk
d'abord ses obsèques exceptionnelle de
retenue et de sobriété avec leurs
instants d'émotion comme l'intervention
du frère de diana vous bien
l'interprétation par elton john de sa
célèbre chanson candle in the wind dont
il avait réécrit les paroles pour
l'occasion
[Musique]
que ta tronche
mais
[Musique]
les
bretons
[Musique]
on a tu vois quand tu
la can
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
faux
[Musique]
là
bravo
quel est ou et vous
[Musique]
on a vu aujourd'hui la famille royale à
l'unisson de son peuple elle qui avaient
tant tardé à prendre en compte l'
immense émotion populaire qu'a suscité
la mort de la princesse de galles bruno
le dreff
où
à cet instant londres retient son
souffle
les gardes gallois qui avait accompagné
la dépouille de leur princesse ont pris
son cercueil sur leurs épaules et ont
pénétré de leur talent dans l'abbaye de
westminster où furent célébrées ses
obsèques
[Musique]
une cérémonie suivie par un million et
demi de spectateurs est ton plus de deux
milliards de téléspectateurs
une cérémonie où se mêlaient le
protocole le plus rigide et la ferveur
la plus populaire qui soit cercueil
recouvert d'un drapeau armes royales sur
un affûts de canon pour le protocole
cris et pleurs de la foule pour une
présence populaire jamais vu
[Musique]
et comme son peuple la reine accompagnée
d'une partie de la famille royale est
descendue dans la rue pour rendre
hommage à la princesse de galles
à
une princesse que la reine avait
dépouillé de son titre d'altesse royale
et pousser ou divorce l'an dernier mais
aujourd'hui la reine s'est incliné
devant elle
mais aujourd'hui pour la première fois
dans l'histoire la reine a fait mettre
le drapeau britannique en berne sur son
château de buckingham
et le peuple anglais a applaudi et le
peuple anglais a versé une larme de plus
lorsque william et harry des enfants de
diana accompagnés de leur père se sont
jointes au cortège
à leurs côtés charles spencer le frère
de diana et le prince philip époux de la
reine
une démarche non prévues au protocole
mais qui pourrait bien marquer le début
d'une réconciliation entre les
britanniques et leur monarchie
devant ces trois hommes et ses deux
enfants le cercueil de la princesse de
galles couvert de fleurs blanches
et ce bouquet avec ce simple mot nomi
maman
derrière 500 représentants
d'associations humanitaires auxquelles
la princesse de galles consacré une
partie de son temps
pendant que le cortège parcourait 5 km à
travers londres l'abbaye de wesminster
accueillait les 1900 invités des
familles spencer et windsor la reine
mère 97 ans et son petit fils édouard
la mère de lady diana et sa famille
monsieur mohamed al fayed le père de
dodi
le premier ministre britannique tony
blair
[Musique]
et puis des célébrités amis de diana lé
chanteur elton john et george michael
le ténor luciano pavarotti
à la demande de la famille de lady diana
la télévision britannique qui
retransmettaient la cérémonie ne réalisa
aucun gros plans des diverses
personnalités présentes
[Musique]
c'est le frère de diana qui lui rendit
hommage un hommage en forme de défi à la
presse et de critique ou protocole royal
elle parlait sans cesse de fuir
l'angleterre en raison du traitement que
lui ont infligé les journaux
elle n'a jamais compris pourquoi ces
authentiques bonnes intentions étaient
tournés en dérision par les médias
pourquoi ils semblaient chercher sa mère
dans permanent c'est effarant
ma seule et unique explication est que
l'otan tiennent bon thé est considéré
comme une menace à l'extrémité opposée
du spectre moral
nous respectons pleinement l'héritage
dans lequel tu es enfants sont nés et
nous respecteront toujours leur rôle
royal nous les y encourage mans mais
comme toi nous voulons qu'ils fassent
l'expérience des moindres aspects de la
vie pour qu'ils s'arment spirituellement
émotionnellement pour les années à venir
mais à la fin de son hommage l'émotion
est trop forte la voix de charles
spencer se brisent
des paroles que les 1900 invités de la
cérémonie et les centaines de milliers
de personnes qui la suivait à
l'extérieur applaudissent longuement
le cercueil de la princesse de galles
prend ensuite la direction du village où
elle sera enterrée et c'est alors que
les caméras britannique nous livre cette
image le prince charles et ses deux fils
c'est unique moment d'intimité et de
tendresse
alors daniel bilalian bonsoir vous avez
assisté ce matin la cérémonie on avait
presque l'impression d'assister à la
naissance d'un mythe ou en tout cas à
quelque chose qui était inimaginable il
ya à peine quelques jours
effectivement venons avant-soirée
naissance d'un mythe ça c'est l'histoire
qui nous le dira mais nous avions
vraiment l'impression aujourd'hui le
sentiment d'assister non pas un
événement de l'actualité mais déjà un
événement historique le maître mot de
cette journée tel que nous l'avons
ressenti si ces émotions émotions jusque
dans la famille royale obligés
pratiquement de descendre dans la rue au
niveau du peuple anglais émotions très
réelle de ce peuple anglais qui
s'étaient rendus en masse sur le tracé
du cortège pour terme au nlhe et de son
amour pour diana bien sûr diana et le
peuple anglais avait eu quelques
anicroches par le passé on lui
reprochait ses fredaines c'est
bonaventure mais tout cela était oublié
aujourd'hui ce qui restait c'était cette
princesse moderne cette princesse des
coeurs comme l'a appelé le premier
ministre britannique émotion bien réelle
que nous avons ressorti lorsque nos
équipes ont parcouru ce matin pendant la
durée des cérémonies les différentes
allées de buckingham palace où s'étaient
réunis la foule reportage de bernard
lebrun philippe deslandes et jacques
garnich
après l'océan de fleurs la marée humaine
celle justement des porteurs de bouquets
qui depuis huit jours à temps ou marc
chevallier pour un adieu à leur diana
dame matinaux silencieux il occupe le
parcours pour les derniers arrivés la
vue sur la rue cela donne ça mais on
accepte sans se plaindre en silence
certains hésitent sont perdus ou
cherchent sur le plan la meilleure place
parmi les trois kilomètres de la
procession
impressionnant la nation réuni
britannique du commonwealth anglais de
la jamaïque ou des indes asiatiques et
musulmans écossais ou anglais ils sont
tous là ensemble dans un rare moment
d'unanimité
perchée ou non quant au loin résonne sur
le goudron le pas des chevaux c'est
l'union nationale on se sert pour
immortaliser la scène ils saluent et
avec dignité
c'est alors que tout un pays se fige
pour pleurer sa princesse
civile
j'aime ou vieux
homme ou femme
et policiers
à ce moment enfin sur le palais de la
reine à part des deux drapeaux en berne
et déclenché une vague
d'applaudissements
cela représente le sentiment de tout le
monde aujourd'hui c'est un geste
merveilleux que la reine fait la
pression
et puis ces pèlerins réconcilier avec la
monarchie vont prendre le chemin dyke
parks ici ont retransmis sur écran géant
la messe à westminster là bas dans la
cathédrale ils ne sont que 1900 invités
alors que dans cette église à ciel
ouvert on rejoue longchamp le jour du
pape avec une foule ou puppy garde il
est vrai mais qui elle aussi intègre les
accidentés de la vie londres longchamp
on pourrait s'y tromper
je pense qu'il y avait beaucoup de gens
qui voulaient participer on voulait
montrer notre respect à diana et c'est
difficile de le faire chez soi si devant
sa télé quand on habite longue ce raid
est regrettable qu'on va venir
c'est si triste
une seule chose a fait se lever comme un
seul homme cette foule effondré de
chagrin lorsque le frère du taiana a
condamné la presse à scandale et juré
qu'il protégerait à vous et william
alors une immense émotion traversa le
parc nourrit d'un espoir que la mort de
diana serve de leçon
émotion intense donc la chair de poule à
fleur de peau comment expliquer philippe
harrouard cette vague de ferveur qui a
submergé aujourd'hui le royaume-uni qui
n'a jamais aussi bien porté son nom
écoutez c'est difficile à expliquer ce
qui est vrai c'est que certainement
parmi ces millions de personnes y avait
beaucoup de gens que la princesse diana
agaçait de son vivant de part son côté
disons superstar ou bien par sa vie qui
était un peu controversé mais ce qui est
vrai aussi c'est que beaucoup de gens
admiraient sa liberté liberté d'élever
ses enfants vide liberté vis-à-vis de
l'establishment et puis aussi sa
croisade contre les malheurs du monde
son engagement sincère envers les plus
pauvres
et bien c'est cet aspect que ce soir les
gens retiennent le plus grand nombre
retient cet aspect c'est d'élire une
femme généreuse et pleine de compassion
même si elle était comme tout le monde
vulnérable et fragile et ce qui est
remarquable c'est que dans cette foule
il y avait non seulement des gens
simples des gens des démunis peut-être
mais il y avait toutes les classes et
toutes les communautés de grande
bretagne unie dans le chagrin et par sa
mort diana a réussi à rassembler toute
une nation qui a parlé d'une seule voix
qui s'est manifestée grandement et bien
peu nombreuses sont les personnalités
qui sont capables aujourd'hui de créer
un tel phénomène après les cérémonies de
ce matin à londres le convoi funèbre est
parti pour alsup à 120 km au nord de la
capitale de l'angleterre c'est là qu'a
été enterrés diana princesse de galles
tout au long du parcours des milliers et
des milliers de personnes ont lancé des
fleurs sur la voiture qui transportait
le cercueil jacques cardoze
le quartier des ministères l'arche de la
garde royale du silence à la foule
dernier voyage de la princesse de galles
à l'entrée de l'autoroute des centaines
d'automobilistes stoppent leur véhicule
pour voir passer le cortège
délices des roses un tapis de fleurs
recouvrait la bentley témoignages
abondent dans le véhicule s'arrête le
chauffeur retire quelques boucs
de londres à althorp 120 km plus loin
des centaines de milliers d'admirateurs
ont manifesté leur peine désormais loin
des regards loin de cette foule la
princesse de galles peut reposer en paix
dans le petit village d'alstom ce n'est
pas dans le cimetière ni même dans
l'église que va reposer le corps de la
princesse de galles mais à l'intérieur
de la propriété de l'immense propriété
de ses parents le compte de spencer dix
septième génération du nom au milieu du
lac que vous voyez sur ces images
aériennes il ya une petite île c'est là
qu'a été déposé le cercueil de diana le
petit village d'al khor attendait cet
après midi sa princesse sa fille du pays
qui rentraient finalement pour le repos
éternel dans cette campagne britannique
si tranquille par rapport à la vie
qu'elle avait vécu ces dernières années
valérie fournis ou pascal car les
habitants du comté sont arrivés à pied
des quatre points cardinaux en famille
progressivement ils ont délaissé la
retransmission télévisée pour voir le
cortège passait de leurs propres yeux
pour saluer une dernière fois l'enfant
du pays
elle revient à la maison chez nous
j'habite northampton et personne ne
pourra nous l'enlever maintenant
des mêmes origines qui crée presque des
liens
tout le monde a l'impression de la
connaître ici et on ne réalise pas
qu'elle est partie c'est depuis sa mort
on réalise sont importantes
ils ont attendu patiemment en suivant la
progression du cortège à la télévision
ou à la radio en évaluant au fur et à
mesure la distance qui les sépare de
diana puis elle est apparue le cortège a
traversé alston le premier village avant
alto hall
sous les applaudissements un bref
passage du convoi funéraire
et rares sont ceux qui ont pu cacher
leur émotion
c'était la reine de notre coeur et on
les met tout simplement
on a dû marcher des kilomètres pour être
ici et même si cela n'a duré que
quelques secondes cela en valait la
peine
j'ai perdu un membre de ma famille
ils sont partis comme ils sont venus
l'âme peut être un peu moins lourde
maintenant que diana repose au pays sur
leurs terres où ils n'ont pu que fleurir
son passage
ce que redoutait avant tout les
habitants d'althorp un petit village
tranquille de 200 âmes à peine c'était
que leurs petites villes deviennent en
fait à un parc d'attractions ça c'était
leur peur suprême valérie fournioux oui
daniel les habitants du village de la
famille de la princesse de galles
craignent l'afflux des pèlerins et des
badauds dans les années à venir au moins
aussi dans les années dans les semaines
qui viennent gudrun tan ce petit village
dont vous venez de parler est
aujourd'hui devenu un symbole comme
arles top hall où diana était enterrée
loin des regards cet après midi loin de
la fureur du monde et les villageois
aimerait également conservé leur
intimité leur tranquillité mais comme
ils ne pourront jamais empêcher les gens
de venir ici une stèle où une plaque à
la mémoire de diana
sera installé devant hunter hall et une
fois par an jour anniversaire de sa mort
les grilles du château de la famille des
spencer seront ouvertes pour permettre
au public de se recueillir sur sa tombe
merci valérie ce matin nous avons montré
les images officielles et officieuses de
la cérémonie cette foule immense massée
sur le parcours du cortège officiel
pendant ce temps là il y avait un autre
londres 1 londres déserté une capitale
britannique pratiquement privé de
voitures ce qui est tout de même rare un
samedi matin dans un pays où depuis
longtemps on a oublié le sacro-saint
week-end reportage d' etienne leenhardt
d'ordinaire à 9h le samedi matin dans
les quartiers commerçants de londres les
russes ont déjà plein à craquer
aujourd'hui on enterre diana et toute la
ville semblant porter le deuil
rafa gars quare s'est mise en berne les
pigeons ont déserté et les touristes
sont ailleurs
au quartier général de scotland yard les
autorités contrôlent plus d'un million
de personnes mais cette foule là est
calme il n'y aura guère d'incidents
11 heures diana entre à westminster les
autobus les trains partout à travers le
pays s'arrête
une minute de silence
dans tous les parcs de londres ils sont
très nombreux des haut parleurs ils nous
ramènent à la cérémonie
[Musique]
à cet instant londres se fichent
précédent 1m d'incidence et semble se
demander pourquoi il est si triste
c'est une princesse qu'on enterrait
et c'est une reine ils ont perdu
[Musique]
après l'émotion il faut tirer une
conclusion politique avec un peu de
recul de cet événement qui a lieu
aujourd'hui il était né nacht la presse
britannique est d'accord pour dire
qu'avant qu'il y a eu avant la
disparition de diana et qu'il y aura
après que rien ne sera plus comme avant
pour la famille royale je croit daniel
que les images d'aujourd'hui en sont la
preuve aucun britannique n'aurait jamais
imaginé voir la reine s'avancer à pied
vers la grille de son palais pour
s'incliner respectueusement sur le
cercueil de son ex belle fille aucun
d'entre eux n'aurait sans doute imaginé
voir le prince charles remonter le mall
cet immense avenue qu'il n'avait jamais
sans doute empreintes et qu'en voiture
et puis il ya eu ces phrases très dur du
frère de diana charles spencer pendant
la cérémonie il s'est engagé à continuer
l'éducation de ses neveux william et
harry à l'image de l'éducation que leur
avait donné sa soeur imaginative at il
dit afin que leurs âmes ne soit pas
engloutie par le devoir et par la
tradition ces mots sont très durs à
l'égard de la famille royale mais la
foule vous l'avez entendu les a
applaudis et la reine s'est peut-être
dit que la semaine finie c'est comme
elle avait commencé dans
l'incompréhension la plus totale total
entre sa famille la famille royale et le
peuple britannique alors charles
saura-t-il bousculer ses traditions et
cette rigidité beaucoup en doutent le
prince william va-t-il prendre la place
de sa mère dans le coeur des
britanniques ces questions qui nous
paraissent peut-être à nous fait-il les
anglais en attendent des réponses
l'émotion de ces derniers jours la
prouver et c'est peut-être là une
victoire une victoire tragiquement
posthume pour la princesse de galles
merci etienne voilà benoît ce que l'on
pouvait dire sur l'actualité de cette
journée ici à l'ombre ce soir la
princesse de galles lady diana est entré
dans l'histoire sous le titre de
princesse des coeurs
[Musique]